Welcome back.
-I miss you horribly.
When was the last time
I was on this show?
-It was pre-COVID. I know that.
It's been a while.
-You did so well.
Thank you for leading us
through dark times
and challenging times.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're a good man.
-You're a light.
You're a light in the world.
-You have two little boys.
How old are your boys?
-Get this.
The oldest one,
Charlie Ocean, is almost 7.
He'll be 7 Independence Day.
-Wow! Independence Day.
Isn't that interesting?
-That's interesting.
And the younger one is
River Joe.
He just turned 5.
-That's amazing.
-Isn't that sweet?
And you have...
-Two little girls -- 8 and 7.
So they're around the same --
Yeah.
-Oh, five years in between.
-Yep.
-How's that?
'Cause we have less
than two years between them,
so they're very --
-No. I'm sorry. 8 and 7.
So they're one year in between,
one and a half year.
Not five year in between, yeah.
-Would you like to take
a recess and compose yourself
before we go on with
the cross-examination?
-Yes, I do.
-3 and 8. You said 3 and 8.
-No, I'm sorry. I meant 8 and 7.
Did I say 3 and 8?
-Yeah, I believe so.
Roll the tape back.
-We could roll the tape back
and see what I said.
Rick, can we play it back?
-That's amazing.
-Isn't that sweet?
And you have...
-Two little girls -- 8 and 7.
So they're around the same --
Yeah.
-Oh, five years in between.
-There was a lot of numbers.
There was a lot of numbers.
I said, "Two little girls --
8 and 7."
Maybe you subtracted
2 from the 7 and then --
Yeah, that's very possible.
-I am an idiot. Wow!
-You would never -- No.
-I've learned
a great lesson tonight.
-Now, what was that?
What did you learn? Already?
-That I'm -- That I have
something wrong with me.
-That's not true at all.
-The bridges are down.
The bridges are down.
-No, they're back up
and they're running.
-8 and 7.
-8 and 7, yeah.
-But what are boys like?
I would have no idea
what to raise --
-Well, you've seen boys.
You know boys. You've seen boys.
-They're very energetic.
-Oh, my God. Yes.
-I have friends that have boys.
They just jump off of stuff.
I know. We were talking before.
I know, "Oh, they're crazy."
I like to say, first of all,
protect yourself at all times,
because they are really --
They are combative
and full of -- they want to --
They want to fight.
I mean, they're taking karate
and ballet class
and different things.
But they are like this.
And I don't know why I'm
the object of their, you know,
destruction, but they're
like -- And they team up.
"Get him! Get him!"
And they want to bring me down.
-Yeah. Of course.
Well, you're a big dude.
-Is that it?
-Yeah, and you like to play.
You're playful.
They want to play around.
-Well, I am. I do like to play.
My wife is kind of bad cop
to my good cop.
-Yeah. You're too nice to them?
-I'm a little nice.
I don't like to get --
You know, she says,
"Hey, don't let them
do that to you.
And, you know,
make them do this.
You're the adult. Come on."
-Yeah, I think my wife
says that, too.
But I'm just like,
"Come on, let's go.
Let's wrestle. Let's do it.
Come on."
'Cause, yeah, they're going to
get to a certain age where
it's not fun anymore.
"Hey, let's go punch dad,"
you know?
And you go, "You're too old.
Too old to be punching dad."
-You know, I remember the day
when I was like --
I don't know -- 13 or 14,
when my dad,
Dr. Harold Goldblum --
I did something wrong.
He rolled up a newspaper,
and he went "Bam" and hit me.
And I just kind of --
I was, I think,
taller than he was
at that point.
-You never forgot it.
-Well, and I kind of looked at
him, and I could tell --
I think I remember in that
moment, something changed.
Something happened.
-He was like, "Wait a second.
Are you going to hit back?"
-Although, it happens now
for me already.
They're faster.
They go "Dada, let's go."
They outrun me.
They do a lot of things already.
-Yeah.
-Oh, yeah.
-Can I just say this,
too, by the way?
You look fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Beautiful jumpsuit.
-Thank you, Questlove.
He goes...
-Yeah, he claps with
his sticks sometimes.
-By the way,
I so loved that movie.
-"Summer of Soul"?
-I so loved -- I saw that
way before -- I saw it early on.
I adored that. Congratulations.
-He did a good job.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-That was great.
-Loved it.
Loved it, loved it, loved it.
-You've actually --
You've been kind of
a fashion icon your whole life.
But this is -- No,
but I have to get into this,
because I was going,
"Jeff, this is fantastic.
I love this."
And you're like,
"Yeah, well, no big deal.
I did a thing with Prada.
I was on the runway."
And I go, "Stop right now.
What did you just say?"
And you go, "I was a runway
model for Prada."
I go, "Wait, Jeff.
You can't bury the lead.
This really happened?"
-Well, I don't know that
I was a runway model.
I mean, for that day,
I was modeling some clothing
and I walked on this runway.
But it was fun. It was fun.
-We got a clip of it,
by the way.
-What?
-Took us five minutes,
and we already got the clip.
Here's Jeff Goldblum
on the Prada runway.
♪♪
-Uh-oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Dude, look at you.
That's great.
-You like that?
-Yes! Wait. That's what you
look -- You look fantastic.
-Yeah, you never
saw that before?
-What were you -- No.
-Oh, thank you.
-We just got it just now.
But how do you --
Was that a character
or is that Jeff Goldblum?
-Well, you know, my imagination
started to -- I don't know.
It's nothing, really.
But my imagination
did start to work.
Although, I was trying
mainly not to trip.
That's what I was
mainly trying to do.
-That was powerful.
-Well, thank you very much.
Before, it just occurred to me
they were playing music,
and I was listening to
the music.
It was unexpected
and unrehearsed.
But I was thinking of -- Well,
that looks a little kind of --
I don't think I was doing
kind of something like that.
But something aggressive.
-It was like...
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was something like that.
-That was good.
-Yeah, something like that.
Thank you very much.
-You got rhythm.
You know how to do it
and own that stage.
I would be nervous.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was thrilled. I was excited.
Mrs. Prada,
very, you know, wonderful.
Very creative Raf Simons.
And, so, they gave me this
to wear tonight.
This is its maiden voyage.
I've never worn this before
tonight. And these boots.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Really?
-Prada knows how to do it.
-Well, I don't know.
-That's so cool
that you did that.
-Thank you, thank you.
-Can we talk about
"Jurassic World: Dominion"?
-Yes, we can.
Well, you're in the family,
of course,
because as you all well know,
"Jurassic World,"
the first one in this trilogy,
directed by the great
Colin Trevorrow --
-Colin Trevorrow, by the way --
-Colin Trevorrow.
-He's a genius.
-Genius, yeah.
-Yes. Einstein was a genius.
Beethoven was a genius.
-Mm-hmm.
-Colin Trevorrow.
-Gandhi.
Yes, and Colin Trevorrow.
-Yeah.
-You were in the first one.
-I was in "Jurassic World."
Everyone, please hold your app--
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hold your applause, and I'll do
autographs after the show.
I can't really...
-I'm star-struck.
-How did they make
the other movies without me?
-I don't know.
-Yeah, the crowds are
just screaming
for my character to return.
-I lobbied the whole time.
I said, "I'll come back if..."
-"Jimmy's not in it."
-James Tiberius Fallon --
-Fallon is not in the movie.
-Yeah. I'm still crestfallen.
-I've got to say,
it is what we want.
We want a big summer movie.
It's time.
We want a big popcorn movie.
We want -- I don't know how he
writes and directs
all this stuff.
-Oh, he's amazing.
And I think what he's done
with this is fantastic.
It is more exciting than any of
the other "Jurassic" movies.
Dinosaurs are all over the world
in this one,
everywhere we are.
And it's more thrilling.
The action never stops.
I saw it --
I've seen it twice now.
The last time I saw it,
I was literally --
This is not -- You know,
I guess I'm here to say
something like this,
but I'm telling you,
this is true.
I was watching it
and I was gripped --
gripped -- and like this.
And there are many scares.
If you like this kind of
thing -- and I do -- I jumped.
I jumped many, many times.
-Yeah.
-And I'm very kind of into
the characters.
You know, I'm in it,
the great Laura Dern.
Oscar winner Laura Dern.
-Oh, yeah, Sam Neill.
-Sam Neill.
-Laura Dern. I love Laura Dern.
Who doesn't love Laura Dern?
-Who does not --
And we're in it kind of a lot.
-The trilogy -- The team --
The band got back together
for this.
-The band got back together.
We would be --
What band would we be?
Everybody says "band."
Would we be
Peter, Paul and Mary?
Yes, of course. That's right.
-That's fantastic, yeah.
-That's right.
-Yeah.
That's exactly who you'd be.
-Or Tony Orlando and Dawn?
-And Dawn? Yeah.
I'm trying to think --
-♪ Tie a yellow ribbon
around the old oak tree ♪
-♪ It's been three long years ♪
-Very good.
So, yeah, we're back together
and we're mashed up with
the great Chris Pratt,
whom you know and adore.
-Bryce Dallas Howard.
-And Bryce Dallas Howard,
DeWanda Wise, Mamoudou Athie.
-I have a photo of you
from the movie.
Here's a picture of Jeff
from the film.
-Yes.
-Here you go.
-Yes. They did --
-Now, wait.
-They did that thing
that they did
to De Niro in "The Irishman."
They made me look much younger.
-No, I love this. Thank you.
We actually found this photo.
I think it was from the
last time you were on the show,
because we were going to
talk about this.
But look how stylish you
were back then.
Prada -- Look out, Prada.
-Well, I apologize for
the Speedo.
-Don't apologize for anything.
We're thanking you for this.
-And it's a little bit like that
pose from the first run.
But that's my backyard
in Pittsburgh.
I grew up in Pittsburgh,
West Homestead,
and that's our backyard.
I'll be darned.
-Yeah. Right?
And you knew how to work it
back then, as well.
Yeah, see?
Prada knows something.
-The glasses are similar,
not dissimilar.
-But this reminded me of this
scene from "Jurassic..."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's what I said.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-But you know what's cool is
that they're making --
-Something's wrong with me.
-No, no, no, no.
They're making merch
for this movie
because people are just -- It's
the biggest thing in the world.
It was the biggest movie
in the world.
And they made this toy.
Well, I wouldn't say it's --
Well, it's a toy.
It's an action figure.
-Yes, yes.
-Yep. This is your great book.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Yep.
-This is your book that your --
-They mocked that up,
yeah, as if I -- as if --
Dr. Ian Malcolm -- that's
the name of my character --
wrote "God Creates Dinosaurs."
-And then, what you get
when you get this...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Boink!
[ Both laugh ]
-Oh, very good.
-Yeah. You're a stud there.
Come on, bud.
-Oh, yes. Yeah.
-Did Spielberg ask you to go --
"Hey, Jeff,
just open up another button."
-No, no.
I don't remember how
that happened, actually.
It was 30 years ago.
And, no, here's what --
Laura Dern --
I was talking to her yesterday.
And she -- Because I said --
People have asked me that.
"How did it happen?"
Did I say, "Steven, please,
let me -- As long as I'm here,
you know,
you don't want to miss this,"
or did he say, "Jeff, please,
come on, let's see something"?
No. I don't think
those things happened.
I think in the,
you know, actorly way,
I think my character --
Even though you see
this thing on the leg --
My leg, of course,
had some difficulty.
I think I had an injury
that is not depicted here.
But in the movie, whether you
see it below the screen or not,
there's something
going on there.
If you can get some evidence
for that, you know,
that will be my story.
-No, that's not --
-But wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
I see some blood there.
There's a blood spatter there.
-That? That is the reason
you had to remove your shirt?
-Yes.
-Because of that?
-Well...
-That is a nick.
That is barely anything.
You don't need to take
your shirt off for that.
-That's excess.
That's excess from something
that was happening here.
I'm telling you.
-Either way, it became a scene
that we all remember
from the movie,
and you're in a movie with
CGI, giant dinosaurs, and, yet,
this is what
we want to play with.
This is --
-I know.
-Yeah.
-Who can blame us?
-What can we say about this --
This is the last
"Jurassic World."
-Oh, maybe, maybe.
I mean, it does,
sort of in a delicious way,
kind of bring us to a sense of
closure and wholeness
from these six movies,
you know, the three parks
and the three worlds.
and all the characters
kind of find some
beautiful...comeuppance
and all that.
But, you know,
this is a chapter closer,
but there may be
more things to the book.
I don't know.
-Oh, really?
-Well, I don't know.
If they like it -- You know, we
offer this humbly at your feet,
and if you want to see it and
you find some pleasure in it --
-Yes! Are you kidding me?
We cannot wait for this movie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to show everyone a clip.
You're fantastic.
Here's Jeff Goldblum in
"Jurassic World: Dominion."
Take a look at this.
-Yeah, grazie.
-We're talking about cascading
system-wide effects, Ian.
-Gosh, that's a drag.
-What is the matter with you?
-Why? Is there something special
you wanted me to do?
-I mean, you know,
if it's not too much to care.
-Hey, I-I gave my opinion
robustly for years.
As expected,
the sum of our human endeavors
has led to our annihilation.
And the only play now is to take
the time we have left and, uh,
you know, just like
we always do, squander it.
-Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jeff Goldblum right there.
Looking good, by the way.
"Jurassic World: Dominion"
opens in theaters and IMAX
this Friday.
Get your tickets now.